i would say the average american is
actually quite has a quite a positive
attitude
toward immigration and historicity and
trying other cultures and so on
in europe the story is different
and not all european countries uh equal
in their um incompetence
or or lack of of doing something
so i think denmark is doing a good job
now of
acknowledging okay we have a problem
we're going to set these programs up and
they're having those debates they don't
agree
um but think about this the social
democratic party which is the center
left
is actually in denmark implementing the
most
far-reaching assimilation programs in
europe
same goes for austria we are seeing
the president of france macron
saying you know what these parallel
societies this islamist separatists
ghettos we can't have that we're going
to have to do something about it and
he's willing
to put his political life on the line
for that
so in an odd sense did the last year
because of the way countries are dealing
with their borders
did it slow down some of this stuff
in some of these countries because
borders were paid attention to maybe a
little bit more carefully just because
of covid
not because of immigration specifically
if if in the past you talked about
borders
and immigration you would be
designated the status of xenophobe
and racist and
you know you know the labels yes
um and so if if you raise the question
of
hey germans french
uk the netherlands scandinavia why don't
we first talk about
assimilating the people we already have
within our borders
before we let in new groups and then
at that point you're having a
conversation about borders
and the knee-jerk
conventional response would be
orders what are you talking about and
then
just follow then along comes kovit and
everybody's closing their borders
and not only that if i were to fly from
where i am now
to any of those european countries i
would be
forced to quarantine for 14 days
in my hotel or home or what have you
and there you have i just faced
violation of your freedom of movement
and your freedom of association and even
in some discussions about kovid
your freedom of speech
and then you say but if you're not
really so you we we would say
we couldn't close borders right we
couldn't talk about borders but now all
we talk about is
come on so in an odd sense that's the
silver lining to this i think right i
mean that's your argument basically is
that
maybe we will be able to have these
conversations because we realize we can
do some things at borders and it doesn't
necessarily make you racist
it doesn't make you racist to say as
elected officials in government
who have been honored with the
responsibility of
allocating the resources that taxpayers
and pay and you know the legislative
process to say
and and most of us you have i have all
of us we've all complied with
what we've been told by those people
that we elected stay in your homes
wear your masks keep the six feet
distance use the hand sanitizer and
we're all willing to do that and we're
very
rational about it i know there are a lot
of people who are irrational but most
people are rational about it
if you bring that same
rational thinking or at least the good
faith
let's talk about islam let's talk about
immigration let's talk about
assimilation
let's talk about the impact that stuff
is having on women
immigrant women muslim women women in
general which is the subject of the book
i think we would then you would say
that's an
optimistic then we've learned our
lessons as societies
the the the opposite way of doing that
putting taboos in things that will
empower the radical islamists
russian trolls it'll empower the extreme
right wing
it will open the door
to authoritarianism let me give you an
example
look at the government of china
when they are confronted
with radical islamic terrorism
their way of doing things is interning
the entire
muslim community like that's 10 million
strong in china
brainwashing them committing genocide
forcibly sterilizing the women we don't
want to go there we don't
literally happening right now what
you're talking about literally happening
right now
that's what happens when you refuse to
talk about things
then you open the door for
authoritarianism what i'm proposing in
the book is
not authoritarianism it is like let's
develop
programs that introduce to young men
from societies that are misogynistic
and homophobic and
where male aggression is either
encouraged
or people are just powerless to do
anything about it
when these young men come into our
societies
let's socialize them into
freedom equality
human rights let's respect their dignity
their human rights and teach them to
respect that of others
we have the time to do that we can do it
that's what covid has shown us like if
we wanted to like
get the resources out there develop the
programs
and incentivize people
to to adopt these values and change
their behaviors
we can do it do you think this is
something that that europe has just
failed at in a way that the united
states hasn't and
and maybe the united states is starting
to fail at it a little bit in
in terms of what locism is doing meaning
that the the idea of multiculturalism in
europe
which is sort of oh you can sort of live
separately
in these countries that's very different
than the united states which was
the melting pot and is the melting pot
still
yeah so i think what saves the united
states
from perhaps going down the path of
europe is that there is this
uh concept and lived experience of the
melting pot
again that's challenged now by
not just the islamists and all sorts of
external adversaries but
also by this homegrown
ideology so in america i think at least
we have the experience we know what it
is
to have a melting point about melting
pots
and and we also reaped
the benefits of that uh i would say the
average american is actually quite
has a quite a positive attitude toward
immigration and historicity and trying
other cultures and so on
in europe the story is different
and not all european countries uh
equal in their um
incompetence or or lack of of doing
something
so i think denmark is doing a good job
now
of uh acknowledging okay we have a
problem we're going to set these
programs up and they're having those
debates they don't agree
um but think about this the social
democratic party which is center left
is actually in denmark implementing the
most
far-reaching assimilation programs in
europe
same goes for austria we are seeing
the president of france macron and you
know what these parallel societies this
islamist separatists
um ghettos we can't have that we're
going to have to do something about it
and he's willing
to put his political life on the line
for that
so i'm seeing changes i'm seeing
differences in different countries
some countries like sweden that's a
total basket case
but in germany again i think germans are
now
truly frightened by the emergence of
these far-right
groups and actually beginning to deal
with
the issue so the united kingdom
again you know i'm seeing changes
um silver linings if you want to put it
that way
um but still not um
of the magnitude like the the situation
hasn't been prioritized
to the extent say that the pandemic was
yeah it's just so interesting to me how
you can
link this to wokism and cancel culture
and everything else because when i was
in sweden when i was on tour with jordan
peterson a couple years ago
we were supposed to do one show it sold
out literally in two minutes
so we added another show and i i chatted
with people
actually during the show and then after
saying well what's going on here that
that jordan's message
about the individual and and liberalism
why is it so important
and everyone said because political
correctness had gotten so out of control
that they couldn't talk
about immigration they couldn't talk
about
gender or or any of the other things
that you're talking about here
and it's like well that's exactly the
purpose of the book so you lay it out
in four parts that i really like so
first you talk about the unsafe streets
i think this is the part when people
when people see videos from germany and
france and some other places i think
this is the part that's probably the
easiest to identify with but can you
talk about that a little bit
yeah so that that part has to do with it
it became incredibly difficult to find
the data
to just call these um offices and say
can you just give me the statistics of
sexual violence in your country
and then you get into all sorts of oh
yeah
right i'll call you back tomorrow um the
dragging of the feet and then they give
you studies that tell you nothing
and sometimes people will say i will
share with you the data but you know
what i don't want my name
or my occupation anywhere i don't want
my fingerprints on it
and so it was okay you know what the
book has i've
everything is in there that i could find
then the next thing is well how can i
illustrate
the problem without only leaning on just
anecdotes and now you go to the
neighborhoods
and some of the women will just really
take you
david to parts of sweden parts of france
parts of belgium
scandinavia anywhere and they'll say
look around what what do you miss what
are you not seeing here
um there's a swedish i think he was a
prime minister but a senior politician
in sweden who was taken to some of these
neighborhoods and he was asked the same
question like
what's missing here and he couldn't come
up with an answer he looked around
what the hell is missing here women
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
international issues instead of non-stop
yelling check out our
international playlist and if you want
to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're all right
over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell